[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman who
just found out about her husband's
secret past
we also talked to a mom of an 18 year
old boy and he's not making good choices
and she doesn't know what to do
we talk to an awesome husband who's
trying to love his wife with mental
illness the best he can
stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john dalone's show
we talk about your life your mental
health your relationships
anything and everything going on in your
world so glad you joined us
if you want to be on this show give me a
shout at one eight four four
six nine three thirty two ninety one
that's one eight four
four six nine three three two nine one
or go to johndaloni.com
ask ask it'd be cool if it was axe i
don't know why that'd be cooler
and by the way you can still tell i am
all kind of
stopped up here in the spring in
nashville i guess it's not even spring
it's the middle of summer
what an idiot i have the summers i don't
know what that means
i think it's a thing but i do think this
will be my delony after dark voice
i think we need to have that show you
guys in
yes we're gonna spin off a delaney after
dark where people
write in their dating advice to a guy
that hasn't dated i don't know like in
20 years i'd be excellent at that
oh man okay so hey i want to follow up
real quick on
a call that we had the last show
so one of the balances i make here on
the show is
between answering a question directly so
somebody calls me with a particular
issue
a particular challenge in their life and
i want to answer it directly
and not use it to splatter paint
um everybody and everything else
or turn it into some social issue some
big
thing and i think social media sucks at
that which is taking a human
issue somebody's hurting right now and
turning it into a
yeah and that's why and then they spray
paint everybody with
the same um paint so
we took a call i took a call last week
on the last show
about um a mom called in and said she
had found her
five-year-old daughter with down the
street and the backyard
friend's house with a couple of little
boys
and they were all showing each other
their
private parts and
we talked a lot about what her and her
husband could do with their daughter
and about how to make sure her daughter
knew that her body was beautiful
that her there was nothing wrong with
being curious
that she's not going to walk away from
this issue with shame the daughter
you know was so freaked out when she got
caught um under a blanket with one of
these
um with a young four-year-old little boy
that she said you know i just
i'm worried you aren't gonna love me
anymore and so we focused on that and
man it bothered me all night that i
didn't
man it bothered me all night into
um for a while that i didn't take the
time
to talk to dads and moms of little boys
we focus more on this particular woman
this particular situation
and i want to back out a little bit
make sure you're teaching your little
boys
they need to keep their hands to
themselves make sure you're teaching
your little boys
that they need to respect
the autonomy of other people and that
comes in the form of not just hey show
me your private parts and trying to pull
someone's pants down
that comes in the form of boys love to
wrestle
they like to put their hands on things
and on people and i love that and that's
good and they need to
have that energy but they also need to
ask permission
they need to be taught can i engage with
you
not just walking around and flexing on
everybody
and i've had to check myself with my own
son because he walks through the room
and i
do it all day i poke him and i will
tussle him and wrestle with him
and it was my wife that said hey you're
teaching him that his body
comes second to whatever you want to do
with it that because you're bigger and
stronger
you get to do you get to poke on him and
mess with him and wrestle with him
when he's not engaged and i realized
you're exactly right
and i watched as
him and other little boys their age do
that to one another
and so i think we have a responsibility
those of us with sons
teach our sons man wrestling is awesome
jiu jitsu
fighting they've got to be prepared to
take care of themselves i'm a big
believer in that
but they also have to learn that their
bodies are their bodies and
other people's bodies or other people's
bodies
and that before they engage with
somebody
before they just start wrestling with
somebody before they say hey you show me
this
that they recognize there are private
parts there are things that are
contextual right your private parts your
private parts you have no business
seeing somebody else's
you don't have permission to pull
somebody's shirt pull down their pants
you don't have anybody you know
permission to
have autonomy over somebody else's body
and we need to start doing
that early early early i spent
you know almost 20 years 17 16 years in
colleges and me and the the sexual
assault statistics
are off the charts they're off the
charts
and i think a lot of that starts with us
teaching our sons
at a young age keep your hands yourself
unless you're engaged in an activity
that everybody's in on
private parts private parts all that
stuff starts at a really young age
and by the way use the right words
create an
environment where your kids can come ask
you questions man make that part of the
fun of being a parent
not like a oh but that's part of the fun
and engage your kids don't let them feel
shame about their bodies but also let
them know that their bodies are their
bodies and other people's bodies are
other people's all right that's it on
that i'm not gonna
just beat that to death all right let's
get right to the phones let's go to i
always say that after spending five
minutes on something else
let's get right to it let's after a long
drawn out delony whining let's go to
michelle
in portland oregon what's up michelle
how are you
hey good morning dr john how are you i'm
good what's going on in your world good
um not much uh oh sorry i'm a little
nervous
hey i'm nervous too and i promise you're
better at this than me so
go ahead okay all right um well
not really sure how to say this but i
just found out recently that
uh my husband has a felony conviction
from before we were married okay and
it's also a registered sex offender oh
okay that kind of felony
yeah so um hey can i ask you something
have you told anybody this uh my mom
she's the only one i've talked to other
than you i guess now um
can you do me a favor yes do a favor i
want you to breathe in real real deep
and hold it for a second
and then let it out
i can hear it sitting on you yeah
when did you find out about this um
actually it's been probably about
almost two months now but okay still
kind of
comes up on occasion
yeah i can imagine so that you're like
hey pass the potatoes
what the f like yeah i totally could see
that
so how did you find out
um actually a piece of his mail um
i found that his yearly he has to
uh register every year with the state
and so they send him like a little
notice saying you have to pay your fine
every year to register
and i found it in the mail um years
do you have kids we do and that's kind
of part of my question
how many um we have two kids together we
have uh
two-year-old twin daughters and i have a
13 year old son from a previous
relationship
so y'all are in this yes five years
and what is his explanation of what
happened why he's on the registry
um well he
was in college um at the time so this
was about 15 years ago when it happened
and he was just at a party and he spent
the night with
a young woman who happened to be under
the age that he didn't know
um it was one night and he didn't find
out until about a week later when the
cop
knocked on his door that's what he said
i got all the paperwork from the courts
and everything
he didn't spend any jail time he just
had some fines and three years of
probation
um and why did he hide this from you
well he says he didn't hide it he just
didn't tell me
he's thought that when we first started
dating we kind of mentioned
something about running background
checks on each other
um and he thought that i saw it on there
and
that it might not have bothered me
it was kind of what his explanation was
so i am
not about it i am way way
if that story is true if you went and
looked at the court records and that
looks right
i am way way way way more worried
that he lied to you that for five years
he's hidden this from you
because he must have had to go to the
mail before you got there every year to
go re-register
what's he do for a living uh he's like a
welder
okay okay so
what'd your mom tell you to do
uh she really she came over that day
because when i first got the
the notice in the mail i didn't really
know what it was because
it just pretty much said you're a sex
offender and no you knew what it was you
didn't want to believe what it was
right i didn't believe it but i didn't
know what type of effects
what it was for was it really for like
did he
really go after a woman um
or was it like what he said um happened
where it was just a one-night
relationship and he didn't know that she
was underage because he was at a college
party
but but hold on i i i don't want to
minimize that
rape is rape is rape right right right
and 15 years ago yes i get that a long
time ago yes i get all that stuff
but it's a college person's
responsibility
if they're going to be wheeling and
dealing right now we have a whole other
conversation be a whole other podcast to
talk about
is it right to to be labeled 15 years
later and all this and that
all that isn't pertinent right now
what's right now is this guy's a sex
offender
you got married you got kids by him and
he's somebody that i would have a hard
time trusting right now
and what you're gonna have to do is
decide
a am i going to reestablish trust with
this person how about this you got to
back out what you all had before now is
completely over
right okay and if you don't start there
you're going to drive yourself crazy
so this idea that everything's perfect
and this is what was
is over there's a period at the end of
that sentence and you're gonna have to
have a season of grieving
that you got had
okay it doesn't mean this thing's over
it doesn't mean that you can't not be
with him but that does mean now
fully wrapping your head around i am
married to a sex offender
right wrong or different and here's the
other thing
you're gonna have to be really graceful
with you
because you're gonna beat yourself up
over this
have you already done that yeah i have
yeah don't do that okay you got had
you got lied to and you can say
i wasn't hiding it you don't just leave
this off this is a conversation
you have before good god almighty
i understand that having this
conversation on date one fair
you gotta have this conversation before
you get married you gotta have this
conversation before you have kids with
somebody period
and you can't say oh i thought you knew
come on man
come on right
so what are you gonna do
um i thought about that for a lot i
i still love them and i mean
on some days it's starting to get to
where you know i don't think about it
and i'll go a whole day without thinking
about it and then the next day i think
about it
yeah um and and we're still doing great
you know the first you know about month
was pretty hard but we're doing a lot
better
um we're looking at possibly going to
speak to somebody
so i'd like to try and make it work
very cool what why why did your your
were you married before no i was not
okay
um but you're you have a 13 year old in
the house
correct okay um yeah
a hundred percent you'll have to go see
somebody okay
and he again i am way more concerned at
this point 15 years later
that he lied to you and
that's gonna continue it's gonna it's
gonna be a seed in your relationship
it's gonna
it's going to grow and fester if you
don't deal with it right now
and so he's still not coming clean with
you he's still in look united said hey i
lied to you i hid this from you i didn't
i thought you were wonderful and i
thought you would leave if you found out
he needs to be that kind of honest with
you
okay and until he does you're gonna
try to make this all go away and it's
just not going to
and you're gonna have to have a response
for
when a neighbor comes by or a future
realtor comes by
somebody's going to pull up that
registry and go what in the world
and this is going to have to be a part
of y'all's life not something you'll
hide and try to
this is going to be a part of your life
right
and at some point you have to sit down
and tell your son because your son's
gonna get someone's gonna look it up at
school
and someone's gonna say what about your
debt you're gonna have to have that
conversation too
and hopefully your husbands of the
caliber now where he would take your son
out before he goes to school and say hey
here's something that happened to me
here's something i'm going to pay for
for the rest of my life
here's how you honor and treat people
here's how you are a steward of
people around you here's our student of
your own body you have to have those
conversations
right you can redeem this thing but it's
man it has to start with
unadulterated clear the deck honesty and
yet you don't have that yet
right i hate that for you michelle
oh it's heartbreaking you're gonna have
to let yourself off the hook for this
okay you are most of us
get married we know somebody we love
that somebody we've been somebody five
years
we don't think oh you know what i need
to do i need to go ahead and check the
we just don't do that
right i hate that for you michelle
listen
sit down and have the hard conversation
you start over that's what's happening
here you're starting over clear the deck
and go get a professional to help you
all walk through this
okay there's gonna be a season of
grieving a season of rebuilding
if you choose to stay with him and then
a season of
how do we do something completely
different than we've done before because
it's got
anything moving forward it's got to be
built on truth all right thanks michelle
all right let's go to caroline in dallas
texas caroline what's going on
is it caroline or caroline carolyn it's
carol lynn
i screwed it up sorry all right carol
hey so what's going on how are you i'm
good
um awesome my question is there's tons
of layers
to it but my main question is i have a
young adult son who recently moved out
i think he's rebelling and so the
control that i perceived i had
is lost and i want to support him but i
don't want to
enable him awesome so give me some more
context how old
is this adult son he just turned 19.
19 all right is he in school is he
working does he do anything
he's not we recently moved here from new
mexico and he had started culinary
school here but one day he came home and
decided that
he was done he was moving back to new
mexico with friends there wasn't
anything we could do about it there
wasn't really much of a conversation and
that was that
okay this is he back in new mexico he is
okay have you been able to breathe yet
um some days um i've
he's living with a friend and a friend's
mom
and i'm just struggling because there's
no accountability or
um there's no he doesn't have any
responsibility to contribute to the
household or take it a job or to move
forward in life and i think that's what
i'm struggling with the most is that
here he had that
and he went to a place purposefully i
believe that he doesn't have that
yeah so you back to what your original
statement is
it sucks when you find out you don't
have any control doesn't it
yes and from listening to another
podcast he was that adhd boy that i
he had lots of chaos in young life i had
him as a teenager
um i had another partner didn't work out
but he was really close too and then i
have the husband who i have now who's
wonderful but
he was four and a half box before that
and so we tried all the things that you
mentioned
taking things away doing all these
things but i think the connection wasn't
there and i didn't realize that until it
was
too late so here's what i want to
challenge you with
never say the words too late with your
son okay
okay right now you're in a season and
he's 19 he's going to flex
in so be it
if he would be willing to one day meet
you in lubbock somewhere or meet you out
in
portalis or clovis somewhere and you all
have dinner
and just say hey you're you're a grown
adult guy
and i love you you're gonna do what
you're gonna do i want you to know you
always got a place at our house
and um i'm not gonna give you money but
i love you
and um i wish you the absolute best
and i wanted him to have that connection
with you
and this is going to sound ridiculous
and silly
but i'm hearing more and more and more
the value of this as people write in
from all across the country
and i've had this experience in my own
life i want you to begin writing him
letters
and here's why you may have heard me say
this before
it's something he can hold on to and his
19 year old brain is looking for every
reason to justify why he just
bailed on you guys and is doing nothing
in some burnouts house in new mexico
and if he gets a letter from you even a
short one once a week
number one it helps you because you're
writing about him it's really a form of
journaling for you
but he's gonna hold in his hand there's
no way he can misconstrue this or twist
this
it's gonna say hey hope you're doing so
well this funny thing happened
we miss you around here we love you and
we hope you're doing great
no you should be doing none of that
because he knows he knows that stuff
right and he's not going to do it and
you harp it on him isn't going to help
um
if he chooses to ever come back with you
of course you can have boundaries there
he's going to be held accountable and
all that kind of stuff
my guess is there's going to come a
moment when he calls you for money
and instead of giving him money i want
you to get him a plane ticket home
and give him a bed to sleep in and then
y'all can begin to
to reconnect there okay but i wouldn't
say
he he's resenting us for things that he
says are i mean
um the person he's living with has very
different views than us obviously and so
he's resenting us
and speaking those things but we're also
like paying his entrance and we've told
him that that's ending
because now he's grown up and moved out
and so but i'm not
i've not ever been good at holding to
that like when the
deadline came i would say well you can
do this instead
or i'll extend it for this or you know
what i mean but i know i've got to hold
them accountable but i know that that's
going to put
more distance between us because he's
gonna be mad that i'm not just letting
him
drive around with my car with my
insurance right does he have your car
well he has a truck that we bought for
him but it's in our name and then we
his insurance is on our policy so what i
would do is let him know hey i'm going
to sell you the truck
and even if you all choose to sell it
for 500 right well below but he needs to
have some skin in that game
say it's in our name we got to get it
off our name um
or you can say hey we bought this for
you this is yours um
we're going to sell it to you for one
dollar so that we can change the title
over
and he's got to do that or you're going
to file stolen
truck charges in 60 days and you're
going to get off your insurance and i'd
give him a landing page
or i mean a landing space don't just say
i'm do cut it off tomorrow
but you can tell them you know in 30
days and 60 days you're gonna be on your
own there
and we love you love you love you and we
wish you the best
i don't have a problem um i resented my
parents at 19
right i don't know a lot of kids that
don't or go through some sort of
yeah they just that's part of growing up
the challenge for parents is to not take
it personally
and not compromise what you believe in
your values
to try to make him like you right you're
playing a long game with him right now
and so your goal now is to hold your
values but also stay connected to that
relationship
and he's got to learn yeah you can't
just pack up mom and dad's stuff and
take off
and have them still fund your life
that's cool man but i love your attitude
if you can keep up even if you have to
hold it together and you hang up the
phone and you cry your eyes out
staying positive when you talk to him on
the phone hey man
um we're gonna go ahead and sign that
truck over to your name but you're gonna
have to buy it from us for ten dollars
or a hundred dollars or ten thousand
whatever y'all think
um okay and we're gonna take you off the
insurance
because you're an adult now he can say
all the resentful things he wants that's
why i want you to continue to pipe into
him once a week
for the next five years 10 years 20
years one year
we love you hope you're doing so great
let us know how you're doing
and but he can't delete those things he
can throw in the trash if he wants to
but it's different than electronic
communication it's something he can hold
in his hands
right and um invite him home for
holidays if he if he wants to
and man let him have his political views
let him have his whatever who cares
about all that stuff that's your son
right um but if he wants to move out he
can move out
okay is there ever a point though that i
i mean because he's not going around
good places he's not going around good
people um and that's been confirmed so
like
i deleted it now because i know you're
telling too but i had
gps for a while and the places he's
going in the middle of the night are not
good or healthy or safe like
in his biological dads and addicts
though that i'm hyper
fearful of that um
you're coming home yeah he's a grown man
controls over yeah i'm struggling with
really realizing that
yeah and you've been through this before
right his birthday broke your heart
and his birth dad's heart was broken too
you see this you see what's what's down
the the
track for your son the only chance
you've got
is not a power play because you can't do
anything about it
the power of the only chance you've got
is connection here
and addiction is a connection issue
right
that's it and whether that's a daily
text or a weekly text and a weekly
letter whatever it is
man that's what you've got
and you're going to torture yourself by
tracking him in the middle of the night
absolutely torture yourself and you're
not gonna do any better for him
you'll it's it's like ruminating right
you feel like it's good thinking it's
not
right you're just choosing to drown
yourself and this is when you back up
and
you really double down on your
relationship with your husband
you all begin to it would probably be
good for you guys to go see somebody
because this is going to bring up
years of grieving that you may or may
not have done
about old relationships about old i wish
i should have
all those kind of things with your son
and y'all are gonna have to have a plan
together you and your husband for moving
forward
and so man heartbreaking but you said it
when you called you're struggling with
this realization that you got no control
you're right it's hard
sucks it's heartbreaking and i hate it
for you
hate it for you
[Music]
hate it for you double down on
connection
you make sure that you be the adult and
you always reach out reach out reach out
stop funding the lifestyle he's a grown
man he's made grow man decisions he can
make
he can have grown-up consequences
and the only chance you've got is
connection you know what i'm gonna
i i said maybe you 100 should
you're going to struggle with guilt
you're going to struggle with what did i
do
it's going to impact your current
relationship i think it's really
important for you to go find
a local counselor there in dallas and
both for you and your relationship your
marriage and make sure you all are
connecting and you're healing
as this goes on it's going to be hard
all right thank you so much hey let's
take a quick break on the dr john
delaney show we'll be right back
[Music]
hey i want to take a quick break and
talk about something important
your mental health if you cannot find an
in-person counselor in your area or you
can't afford one i've got a solution
i've partnered with better help for
customized online therapy
for you video chat phone or even text
chat counseling
with licensed therapists that are going
to help you
become a better version of yourself help
you
get on the road to being well go to
betterhelp.com10
off your first month this is less
expensive than traditional therapy
and you're worth it betterhelp.com
take care of yourself start today
all right let's go to john in atlanta
georgia john what's up man
hey dr d how are you i'm awesome hey
listen
so inside baseball
what in the world happened last time we
were supposed to meet you're supposed to
be on the show
a few shows ago and what happened
well i was trying to be a good citizen
since i'm a firefighter um and
uh didn't want to talk while holding the
phone uh
in the car and i'd try to pull over
quickly and uh forgot that i had a
trailer on the back of my truck and
sideswiped a car it was awesome
you got so was your fault 100 my fault
oh man are you okay oh it was it was
like a fender bender my the wheel well
of my trailer just went into their door
and
caused enough damage that the police and
of course my firefighter buddies had to
come and make fun of me and
it was awesome oh that's outstanding so
this call is costing you thousands of
dollars right
well luckily enough my deposit was or my
deductible is only 500 but i'm sure my
insurance will go up so yes
but you're worth it i suppose this
you know you'd love to say that this is
the advice is worth what you pay for it
and you always say that it's free so
this is not the case
oh man i know i'm gonna have to ramp it
up a notch dude you
like uh man well i'm glad you're okay
and i wish you were a better driver
because now i feel all nervous about
this call
i can't screw this up you're a
firefighter you actually help other
people
and you're clearly not a nascar driver
which is a good thing
all right so john how can i help what's
up
okay brief synopsis is uh i um met my
wife and we started dating a little over
three years ago
and then we've been married just about
two now
um and while we were dating uh and then
subsequently engaged
she uh went on to tell me that she had
suffered from anxiety and depression
um but you know we weren't living
together so i didn't get to see the in
and out we weren't living together until
we were married
i didn't get to see the ins and outs of
every day um
and right as we were about to get
married
maybe two weeks beforehand she kind of
alluded to that it was much more than
she had
let on um and provide sort of provided
me an out was like hey
if this mental illness is worse than
i've told you about
is that something you're going to be
able to handle and if not i'd understand
if you don't want to
you know go through with the wedding and
we were getting married in two weeks and
it was a destination wedding and people
had already had their tickets and
everything was paid for so i mean what
am i going to say at that point like
nope let's not get married
um uh and then hold on let me let me
stop right there
did you ask for more information then
if i would you just hug her did you just
hug her and like have a notebook moment
and then say i'm with you forever and
it'll be fine pretty
yes pretty much that i in it's how i
feel now is that like
that i mean 100 i was in then if i'm
gonna
if i want to spend the rest of my life
with her i want to spend the rest of my
life for better for worse
that's right um so i did not pride no um
and i felt that honestly if it was on
her heart like when god put on her heart
to divulge all that it was
it that would be in her time i didn't
want to push her to
tell me more um in retrospect i probably
wish i would have
a little more um because it was almost
like once we got married
a switch sort of flipped uh i i can
definitely correlate that to living
together
obviously you see a whole lot more of
people um
inside that you don't normally see and
then the fights just were
uh i mean full disclosure is that i was
not i'd like you to say all the times i
did not have the tools in my toolbox to
lead my way through this but the fights
to me were just incredibly illogical
like we would argue about things that
and i've been married before this is my
second marriage so i know what it's like
to be in a marriage where
little fights happen over nothing but
this was beyond anything i'd ever seen
and
one fight got particularly bad that i
had to involve her mother in
um her mother went on to did you uh yeah
oh because i was worried about her
safety to be honest with you yeah but
all right man when you still no no at
one time my time let me back up too this
was also uh
at her suggestion which was hey i think
you should talk to my mom about some
stuff that's going on she could probably
help you
navigate this so this was at her
suggestion also
um and at that fight her mom basically
said mandy i think it's time to tell him
the full truth of what's going on
um and that full truth hold on so her
mom knew that she had been
holding things back from you and lying
to you before you got married
uh i don't think necessarily she knew
that i think it came out
in this big in that big fight that i'm
referencing you had no idea
correct okay and before you keep going
i wanna just wanna back up for anybody
listening to this
it is not quote unquote prying
to get full disclosures of medical
issues and mental health issues of
personal challenges of past history
you are the idea of marriage is to
become one
you are hitching yourself to somebody
else and saying ride or die to listen to
the wheels fall off this thing
it is not prying it is not like hey
digging in
it's not hey you can tell me on your own
time man you got to talk
you got to talk to each other man um
sure
and if you're on the other side of this
and you're with somebody and you're
dating somebody or you're thinking about
it
you gotta be honest you gotta tell the
truth otherwise
you become you're it's not just my
personal thing it's deceitful
you're lying you're not telling truth
and i know it's hard to wrap your head
around
um the woman you love but wow and um
okay so
you things get so bad you gotta call mom
and then what happens
she went on to tell me that she is uh
clinically diagnosed
um with bipolar type one okay um
she has a personality disassociative
disorder
um a moodle ability kind of the same
thing in that same category and then
severe anxiety
and depression okay um she does have
substantial fast traumas um molestation
by family members and then when she
reported it to her parents her parents
basically told her she was a liar um
she has a lot of traumas that in her
past
and the long short of it is that in the
beginning i was
you know so confused and i
was not a deloney disciple at that point
um
and being a critical care paramedic and
a firefighter
i did what i'd say the more i hear your
show most
guys do who have the best of intentions
is i
tried to fix it try to go solve it
that's right yeah
yeah and i really had the best of
intentions and it just was not what she
needed and i didn't know that at the
time
um uh and that's hurts my heart that i
maybe furthered her um
her state at the time um
i wish i could say that was all all the
problems that we had aside from the
fights and the ups and downs of bipolar
people don't realize
people say all the time just friends of
you know not friends of mine just people
around like oh
my spouse has bipolar but i mean i think
there's a
big misconception about what bipolar is
especially when someone is
bipolar type one it's one of the most
over
um over diagnosed
diagnostics there is it's just a
catch-up it's become just a catch-all
and when you're actually around somebody
that truly has
t1 bipolar you go oh there it is
right it's uh it's tough yeah it's very
hard on everybody
um you said there's other other things
going on what else happened
well um there was uh
dude in the fights and back and forth
and this correlates back to me of
she felt like i wasn't there for her or
i wasn't um
being what she needed in these
situations so it caused her to
venture out of our marriage on two
separate occasions
and it was early on in our marriage um
she
in retrospect told me she was very
unhappy and all these different things
so two different affairs essentially can
like back to back
over the course of like a four and a
half or five months period um
and that was in the beginning of last
year um the end of 2019 beginning of
2020.
she said it was never anything physical
and i actually do believe her we've had
a lot of counseling and therapy back and
forth
over it but it was when any time the
person that you love
goes somewhere else for satisfaction
even if it's just emotional satisfaction
it's it's a hard pill to swallow yeah
that is i'll go ahead top it all off i
gotta hear this one
um so it just was in it was
after talking i've been in therapy
pretty much the whole time since it
seems like it was
as a result not necessarily as a result
these things were definitely weighing on
her about her feeling
terrible about herself she
attempted suicide last year
uh in june of last year man i'm sorry
so we just had the one year anniversary
of it and
uh it's been it's been a really really
hard two years yeah
and really the reason why i'm calling is
not to i feel like i'm
uh venting or complaining and i'm not
it's
a more calling for encouragement because
uh so often we hear
a verse and i have it written on my fire
helmet underneath the brim of my fire
helmets that man knows no
greater love than this that one would
lay down his life for another
and my whole life especially being a
firefighter for the past 17 years
i have always thought about that as
literally laying down your life for
someone dying for someone else but
god's almost put on my heart that you
can lay down your life
on a daily basis for someone and like i
said earlier i'd choose her for better
for
worse would i leave her if her if her
diagnosis or her illness was cancer
or some other debilitating disease i
would never so why would i consider that
in a mental illness situation so uh
i'm more calling for encouragement or
you know when the days get hard
yeah so number one
yeah yeah it's real hard man and so
first thanks for
sharing that and for those people who
live with somebody or love somebody
who's got bipolar um there's not gonna
be a dry eye on this call because
they've lived what you're going through
and so here's a couple of things to step
back and
you may know this but hopefully i can
say it really clear for you
when you've got somebody who suffered
physical abuse sexual abuse especially
at the hands of loved ones
the reason that is so evil
is it makes the only thing that can keep
somebody well
which is relationships it becomes the
weapon
so her brain has been scanning her
environment for the last
20 years 30 years looking for
somebody trying to get close to her
so that she can sound the alarm so that
person can never get hurt
and never hurt her again and now that
person is you
right and so there's part of her brain
that knows you're the safest most loving
most wonderful person on planet earth
and there's a part of her brain deep
inside that says get away from this guy
this is going to happen again
and it's going to happen again and it's
gonna happen again right
that's what trauma does and when folks
stepping out on me on relationships
marriages that's a common thing with
bipolar one
right you probably were told that in
therapy um
sexual acting out addiction just running
and running and running and running
until
somebody collapses and then not running
right
just like the whole world is paused um
it is
hard does she have medical care she
taking her medication
yeah she's been great about it she has
fought
hard over the course of the past year i
think the suicide i mean she did uh
she scared everyone including herself
with her suicide attempt
she she meant it when she tried it
wasn't like one of those things to cry
for attention in any way she
so it scared her and she has worked
tirelessly
over the courses we both have we i have
not only
fallen in love with your program you
have helped me more than you can if i
could ever put into words just with
the tools that you keep putting in my
toolbox but i appreciate that man she is
and we but she's been seeing uh her uh
clinical psychologist as well as a
site or i'm sorry clinical psychiatrist
pardon me as well as our psychologist
that we both see independently and
together
good so here's here's the things that
you're gonna need to do
okay okay it's gonna sound
counterintuitive
but you are gonna have to really work
hard
on making sure you're okay
think of yourself as a stake in the
ground
into bedrock okay and you are married to
somebody who on some
parts of that month and you'll know what
i'm talking about loves you with an
intensity
that people only dream about
when it's good it's real good isn't it
it's the best
you're the most incredible person who's
ever lived right
maybe this is a terrible analogy and so
i hope the internets don't beat me up
for this
it's kind of like a tetherball and you
were that
you were the pole and you married a
a a bird who is constantly flying all
over the place but she's tethered to you
and sometimes man it is the greatest and
sometimes it feels like you're
the whole thing's gonna fall over right
yeah and i said tetherball and bird i
realize that doesn't all work out
together
but um you've got to be that rock in
that center
which what does that mean it means you
got to be diligent about taking care of
your physical body
you got to exercise i know you're a
fireman i know you all do that you got
to be really diligent about having guy
friends in your life
other men who will hold you accountable
who will laugh with you
who will you go get a drink with you can
just go be with right
you have to be really really diligent
about continuing to
take care of your mental and spiritual
self right have people in your life
whether that's a counselor whether
that's a good pastor whatever that looks
like for you
and then you're gonna have to just soak
up the great great times and then you're
gonna have to default to routine and
practice when things get hard
and i love your spirit you're in it
sounds like you were in it all in it
and then you're gonna have to be able to
hold your wife accountable
she's gotta take her medication i've
seen some really remarkable success
stories with folks who will continue to
take their meds
and it's hard when things get really
good for a season man it's easy to stop
taking your meds and that's when you've
got to double down and make sure you're
still taking them
um and people who with bipolar they
really really miss the high parts
because it feels so good
right and right y'all gonna have to be
in that part together
but yeah you've anchored yourself to a
hurricane which is great
and hard and messy
and it's going to come down to you
taking care of you
that's hard it's real hard
we have five kids students i don't i
don't really get much of a break could
say that
you have five kids we do
together uh no she has too biological
from her previous marriage i have two
biological from my previous marriage and
we haven't adopted one between us
you all adopted a kid too yes sir
when did you all do that what does the
last two years been like for y'all
a little bit of a wild ride what are you
doing yeah
ah man john you're my hero today
yeah you don't get much of a break you
know what that means it means you
absolutely have to have a break
okay and you're gonna have to do
something that firefighters do not like
to do
you're gonna have to ask for help
and you're gonna have to demonstrate for
your kids all five of them
that the best way you can love other
people is to love yourself first
to make sure you're healthy first
right yes sir and you know this from
being a fireman you're of no good
to a people in a burning building you're
no good in an ems situation if you
haven't slept
and if you're not feeling good and if
you're not thinking clear right
how much more important than it is for
your kids right that means you're gonna
have to have somebody come over and take
care of those kids while you go work out
and you're gonna have to have somebody
come over if you need to sleep if you
and your wife need to go on a date
it's gonna have to be part of your life
a regular regular part
but i'll tell you this those guys those
kids won the lottery with you as dad
your wife won the lottery that you're
gonna have to have places where you can
go
lay down and be vulnerable too at some
point if you are so strong all the time
that's
that that poll is going to snap right
yeah i feel it coming to be honest with
you okay
then what do you got to do
is it the hard part i mean i get the
concept it's just where do i find that
time is
i just scares me
what do you got to do just take care of
myself
so where are you going to find the time
you just have to
you just have to be intentional about it
and do it
that's exactly right how old are your
kids
[Music]
uh 7 8 9 10
13. awesome they are old enough now
that you can bring them in here's what i
want you all to do as a family
this is going to be fun you probably
heard me tell other people this
but this is going to be good for your
soul and for theirs i want you all to go
to michael's like some crafty store
and i want you to get a hobby lobby one
of those kind of stores i want you to
get a
a giant canvas is your wife an artist
she actually does like it a lot yes yeah
a lot of folks at bipolar
find a lot of peace in art i want you
all to also get some stick on letters
and i want you all to create the family
values of your new family
here's who we are here's how we treat
each other we do
we do hard work we do hard things we do
chores we treat each other with respect
and i want you all to paint it i want
you all to have a family event as you
all come up together
all seven of you god almighty seven
people
bro all seven of you and i want you all
to create this together
i want you to hang it somewhere in the
living room and i want your wife to
play a key role in the artistry of this
and the peacemaking of i want i want all
of you all to be a part of this
here's who we are and then i want you to
begin to roll off tasks and chores to
these kids
let them know that they play a
cornerstone role in this house
whether that's dishes whether that's
making breakfast for one another and for
the family
whether that's helping with dinner prep
whether that's helping with yard prep
whether it's helping you and your side
job because all firemen i know have side
jobs
all they're going to play a key role and
what that's going to allow you to do is
a
teach them responsibility autonomy
strength resilience
they're going to learn words at that
meeting on how to help mom when mom's
not doing well
how to to lean on you
and not on mom during those hard seasons
and how to lean on mom and not on you
when you're having hard seasons and as a
fireman you will
and then you're going to begin to create
space and you're going to lead the way
for that family saying
i need one hour a day to go work out
i need one hour a day to journal to do
prayer time to do
meditation time because this is when i
take care of me
and that means you all are going to take
care of each other you're going to
model that for them and they're going to
hold you accountable like my
two little kids hold me accountable dad
you probably should go exercise you're
kind of being
grumpy today and you're gonna build it
and build it and build it
and then you're gonna have a group of
guys that you reach out to and you tell
your kids
daddy's gonna go be with his friends
tonight they're all old enough to stay
at home by themselves now
and you're going to step out you're
going to model that you're going to
model friendships you're going to model
taking care of yourself you're going to
model taking care of your wife when it
gets hard
loving like crazy when it's good
and you know this better than i do there
is not an easy road
it can be a deep and rich and fertile
road but it won't be an easy one
and dude you say that um
i'm some kind of hero i'm not brother
you're the hero here
you're doing the hard work i just talk
on the podcast
you're doing the hard work day in and
day out and for all first responders out
there
i used to show up on scenes it's way
easier to show up on a scene and help
somebody else
than it is to do the day-to-day grind in
your own home
it's way easier
every first responder i know it's easier
to show up at a car wreck it's easier to
show up in a burning building it's
easier to show up in a tragic situation
than to be patient and kind on a daily
basis that's hard
we can do this y'all can do this thank
you so much for your call brother john
we're thinking about you let us know how
i can help as we
as you make this journey with your wife
and your five kids
whoo you're in it all right as we wrap
up today's show
i was just jamming on the song on the
way here and so i thought
why not here we go
i don't remember when this album came
out it was in the 90s
and it was their comeback comeback
record when they all got sober
allegedly it's off the dr feelgood
record
self-titled by the one and only motley
crew and it goes like this
rat tail jimmy is a secondhand hood and
he deals out in hollywood
got a 65 chevy proper flames
traded for some powdered goods i don't
know what he's talking about
jigsaw jimmy's running a gang but i hear
he's doing okay
got a cozy little job sells the mexican
mob packages of candy cane
he's the one they call dr feelgood he's
the one that makes you feel all right
he's when they call dr feelgood he's
gonna be your
frankenstein
at night he'll always be found selling
sugar to the sweet
people on the street they call this
jimmy's town and they call this
dr john dolone's town show i don't know
i was trying to make something cool and
it didn't work
this is the dr john delaney show
you